مشهد الاحتجاجات في ايران لا يختلف بين
2019 و 2022 القمع في مواجهه التظاهرات
عنصر ثابت في المكان مع تغير الزمان الفرق
يتمثل في نفس الاحتجاجات فالسابقه ولدت
والحاليه مستمره رغم كلفه الباهظه من
الضحايا بلغه الارقام
326 شخصا على الاقل لقوا مصر من بينهم
اطفال ونساء وافقا منظمه حقوق الانسان في
ايران غير الحكوميه التي يقع مقرها في
اوسلو خلال الاحتجاجات الجاريه التي فجرها
مقتل مهسا امين على يد الشرطه الايرانيه
وقبل سنوات ثلاث سقط ازيد من 300 قتيل في
حين تحدثت مصادر اخرى عن حصيله تجاوزت
الالف ولان الذكريات لا تموت خاصه في
وجدان الشعوب دعوات من ناشطين ايرانيين
الى تظاهرات كبيره هل اسبوع المقبل لاحياء
ذكرى من دفعوا حياتهم ثمنا لها انذاك
التظاهرات المتوقعه تشمل المدارس
والجامعات والاسواق خاصه في العاصمه طهران
حتما سيكون يوما عاصفا في وجه النظام
الايراني الذي لا يتقن سوى لغه القمع في
مواجهه احتجاجات سلميه تطالب في كل مره
برحيل من قتلوا وشردوا الالاف من
الايرانيين منذ سيطرتهم على الحكم سنه
بلال البوجدين العربي